A pinhole camera captures an image upside down. In computer graphics we think of
a camera a bit differently with the image being formed in front of the viewer.
This is a more convenient way to consider the task of image generation. For
starters, now the object projects onto our screen right side up. This
pyramid-shaped view of the world is called the view frustum. Frustum means a
pyramid with its top chopped off. It is one of the most frequently misspelled
words in computer graphics. So, lock it in your brain now. There's no letter r
in the last half of that word. I suspect it sneaks in there because of the r in
the word frustrate or maybe the word fulcrum. Anyway, enough about that. The
point here is that we want to know how much light is coming from each direction.
Each light emits photons which bounce around the world and may get absorbed or
otherwise changed. In a camera we gather photons from the world and these create
a photograph. In computer graphics, we simulate the real world as best we can
and try to determine how many photons are coming in each direction. Whatever
amount of light we gather from a direction, we record at a pixel in the screen.